hello I'm Paul cowling with film
independent and welcome to this week's
coffee talk before we start a reminder
if you're watching this live that many
is for members
promotion right now is still running so
if you know anyone who's not a member of
film independent you can nudge them get
them to join discounts available just go
to from independent walk for more
information also this is our first event
in a couple of weeks and we were
scheduled to have lynn shelton and
kimberly peirce two weeks ago and pushed
about a week due to lindsay list but of
course sadly she passed away
so we're dedicating today's event to the
memory of lynn Shelton today our guests
are two very busy men who are not quite
so busy but still managing to stay
productive during the lockdown first up
he is the director of George Washington
all the real girls pineapple express
stronger many many other movies plenty
of TV credits to his name with his
longtime collaborator Johnny McBride
including eastbound and down Vice
Principals and righteous gemstones
he and Danny have also resurrected the
Halloween franchise in a planned three
movie trilogy the second which comes out
at the end of the year so this today is
the great David Gordon Green David how
are you too bad I mean in Charleston
South Carolina hanging in there just
just go back to the office today which
is kind of interesting and eerie being
the only one here but that's kind of
cool yeah we'll ask a little bit about
Halloween kills a little later on
because I know you said you're you're
almost done right yeah finishing that up
right now
and when I asked you who you wanted to
chat with you suggested your good friend
Craig Zobel whose credits include great
world of sound compliance film that
really got Sundance talk z for Zachariah
his TV credits include directing for
many of the hot shows right now American
Gods Westworld leftovers he's current in
the middle of a new HBO show directing
every episode of mayor of east town
and his most recent future the hunt was
released of the lockdown so he's
seriously affected by this craig zoobel
welcome oh great
hey how's it going guys I didn't know
you were I'm currently in Philadelphia
actually where we were mayor of this
town for HBO show before you know put it
on pause okay we'll ask you a little bit
about that later I'm sure and for people
listening in there's a Q&A button at the
bottom of the screen so you can type
your questions in there we'll get to
those a little later on but right now
I'm going to step off this virtual stage
and there are two guests today
sounds easy yeah I just thought when
Paul asked about this I thought it'd be
cool to catch up with you just in terms
of I think your of our circle of friends
you're the person that's had the most
interesting year it's good to give a
little context to people of how we know
each other but we go way back to to film
school and I was just thinking on the
way over the office today of like not
just we're classmates but we would do
sit like I would remember
gross national park space shuttle I mean
there were a lot of yeah yeah we've
known each other for I don't know 20
years we were in it was we were in a
movie together right is that what ghost
National Park what I'm trying to
remember what that was yeah it was I
mean I it was like our friend who was at
FSU from schools Matt Chapman one of the
most erotic guys he shot us yeah
yeah that's good stuff um yeah I mean
it's been it's been a wild year it's
been I'm curious to hear like what
you're up to
because I know you were sort of near the
post by the time like yeah we were we
were we were locking picture we just
locked picture on Halloween kills and we
were two days into shooting the
righteous gemstones season two so in
some ways as far as my selfish concerns
it was an interesting time to pause
because the completion of one big effort
and thought and the anxiety of another
of the upcoming one you know we're just
sticking our toes in the water of
gemstones within pause that and actually
have to pause that one for at least a
year so it's gonna be awhile to to sit
on those ideas and see you know thanks
Danny and I've been talking about it's
like how are the story is that we were
and I don't know if this is something
you're considering to but how are the
stories that we're in progress of
telling gonna be relevant or evolved or
should they or shouldn't they you know
that's gonna be kind of an interesting
absolutely totally like I mean I was
looking back over the because we had
nine weeks to go and and the whole this
shows out cross boarded which is the
same was like shout out Oh unaware there
was we weren't doing episode by episode
but it was just kind of like one giant
giant thing for all the episodes so
which has been interesting in that like
in some ways it's good that we've had
kind of stuff in like the first and the
last episode that is finished that's
like does have like a bunch of extras in
it and stuff which you know I'm assuming
we won't have the rest of it but it's
just a minute shame it's like there's
like there's scenes that are not shot
yet we're like in the scene like one
person is like sick and the other person
like feels their forehead and like you
know like sits down beside them like can
you even put that in I mean I would feel
weird I would be I would certainly be
thinking about like how that was a story
that was told before couldn't
sorry good it's a contemporary story
though it is I mean it's like kind of
it's kind of based like like in the
winter of of 2019 so yeah yeah it's
conceivably like it could you know it's
right before so that if you have to kind
of like break it down with Halloween the
one we just finished there's a lot of
big mob scenes and there's I mean it's
it's a movie that you you know in a
weird way we wouldn't be able to make
for a really long time and it will just
be interesting if we keep on the release
scheduled supposed to come out in
October or in the middle of October and
if we keep up with that it'll be
interesting coming out of this just that
that environment is gonna be so so
radical and you know on top of our
quarantine also now getting the
injection of bigger picture headlines
and things like that that are starting
to make the world a very volatile place
coming out of a quarantine so yeah just
an ever evolving situation our realities
and in our professional life yeah I mean
I do I do wonder like how much like
that's a not like what I just gave this
obvious example of like things that
story that's gonna change because of
this like in the sense that like I just
would be distracted like I would even
knock me out for a second so like see
somebody who is like coughing and house
of my next let's sit down to them and
the next of them like I would start to
think about like that this was conceived
outside of the thing I mean I don't know
you know I'm Kerri what I'm most curious
about is like what is going to feel like
we
what do we want to talk about I'm not
sure I know yeah you know well I haven't
been watching much TV or reading I
actually have not been very productive
outside of you know finishing touches
score it's been I've been working with
the composers remotely and things like
that but haven't been super productive
one thing I have watched is I rewatched
the the Ken Burns documentary on the
Dust Bowl which it was really fun I
watched that was my kids just to show
kind of a historical perspective of a
radical time that my grandmother lived
in Oklahoma during that and was in
quarantine basically for many years
where outside was a dangerous place you
know it was so it was fascinating
watching the the depths and details of
that situation from you know my
nine-year-old perspective and knowing
that they had a great grandmother that
lives through this thing so I don't know
I think I think as any historical event
people evolve and change in the dialogue
either either that swept under the rug
or it becomes a pivotal turning point in
the mindset and both of what you're
fascinating it's like and it's also just
kind of interesting just to be like it's
like are people gonna want to just not
think about like do we need to like are
we gonna find ourselves wanting to tell
stories that are like and for lighter
kind of like like is it are people gonna
want to tackle like oh this is stories
right now I don't know I actually don't
know I don't know I don't personally
have an opinion really you know like
because I do know that have you been
able to say you're not like kind of
working very much like a movement like
I've had it's been challenging for me to
be as creative as if somebody plops down
and somebody had told me like a year ago
guess what like you you just get a free
like three months that you can just do
whatever you want to I would have
thought I would have no like written
seven scripts at this point but
well I mean yes I am the same way but I
I think you and I both have been on such
a professional rampage for lassic lack
of a better word for the last two years
like you haven't well it your heart
you're a hard man to get a hold up every
time I call you're on them you're in a
mix or prepping something or shooting
something or you know there's always in
there's overlap so a lot of those things
are happening at the same time and and
you could say the same thing for me
we've been very fortunate in that way to
have a lot of opportunity that I feel
like the greatest gift of of what this
period has been as the mental reset is
to be able to take a deep breath and
think about things and not be productive
so it's a little bit of a different
philosophy but it's more for me it's
more reflective knowing that I don't
think I could self-impose that type of
of a gift of time to myself but to be
mandated to do it is really helpful to
me you know I don't know
that's kind of what we talked about
earlier in the lockdown like I you know
it's like I have found myself I like you
know I deleted Twitter the other day I
was happy about that like I needed to
actually just have like time that
somebody else told me to like wait for a
second um and which is you like you say
it's like incredibly like I feel lucky
that I am in that scenario because
there's certainly been years of my life
where I haven't felt like that so great
but like it's been it is it has been
interesting I've actually started like I
took up like I've been taking my camera
out and just like doing like four or
five mile walks like I'm around this
town but I don't know and take just take
I don't know if I'm taking good pictures
but I'm just like I feel like just like
doing using you're being creative
different way has a reset yeah yeah
doing something different I think it's
good like Wednesday laughs like when did
things kick into gear for you is it
leftovers where everything just started
going one thing to the next
yeah it was it was right yeah the second
season was when I started four years ago
yeah so yeah I mean I'm always thinking
about it when you see these satellite
photos of the earth and the lack of smog
and pollution in so many cities I'm also
looking at my brain as you know by
minimizing some of the inputs sometimes
like I won't look at the news except
between 11 a.m. and 3 p.m.
anything else you know lightning can
strike me in the middle the night at all
that that middle of the day period is
the only time I want input but I really
want a clean subconscious to be able to
independent rains which i think is
probably a result of minimizing input so
there's that whatever that is you know
you know kind of as David Lynch
excitement about that you know yeah I
mean it's crazy it took me a second I
have stated like in just in the sense
that like I we were the you know the
hunt was like being released like the
last week of it so it was like back up
to the hunt because that's an
interesting story to talk about so that
was not always supposed to come out a
long time ago give a little context for
the hunt and then everybody should go
see that but yeah it's actually on DVD
and blu-ray and like two days ago
I'm not intentional but there's like but
yeah like so how was a script I have a
great experience
work on the leftovers with with Damon
Lindelof and Nick Q's who's a the other
writer who did a lot of the episodes
that I did for the leftovers and it was
really like it was it felt very creative
and collaborative and it was it you
always say at the end of a project with
people you guys say like let's do this
again it was like let's do this again
like this was great this was really fun
and so they had been thinking a lot on
the left there's a lot about conspiracy
theory because of kind of what the
Lefter is about and had just and had
basically been talking about that a
bunch of it had seen an avenue to make
something that could be like a fun
horror movie that engaged like kind of
like modern what modern conspiracy
theory and q and on pizza gate kind of
stuff which is which is the story of the
hunt you know it's essentially like
update of the most dangerous game but
we're a group of like very rich you know
kind of like coastal elites or something
are like are like being have decided to
hunt a bunch of everyday people who they
feel like have like wronged them in some
way and it was intended to be pretty
tongue-in-cheek the whole scenario but
in pen and I you know and we shot
through me and like got through most of
at Oriel and we're actually in like the
sound mix of the movie and doing doing
test screenings and getting her feedback
and feeling like people were receiving
it the way we intended which was like
this this pretty playful like fun film
when the El Paso El Paso and they know
higher
mass shootings happened and then sort of
in response to two especially the paso
shooting had you know the guy had like
written a manifesto that was very based
on kind of like a lot of talking points
from like politics and because of that
like it became the the spotlight got
turned on on the hunt in weird way like
in definitely in a way that was like
immediately like it was on not
necessarily on like mainstream media but
like on like right barred and Sebastian
Gorka and he's kind of like is like
pretty you know to the right extreme
group started to like point out those
maybe in like and like go after it which
culminated in the president tweeting
that I was racist against Trump
supporters for making the movie and then
then the movie he got got polled because
because we were getting enough like
there was enough kind of like people
calling in to Universal and like being
like who hadn't seen the movie didn't
there really was but just sort of like
three like what the narrative had been
like you know decided that we so crazy
just like you know it's one thing when
you know you see your buddies in a movie
you get really excited but when you see
your buddy's name and these headlines
like wait that's Craig from from college
you know it's it's a got pretty wild and
and it's it's interesting when the
stories that we're trying to tell with
whatever intentions that we have aren't
necessarily even being listened to at a
point and I think that's something I
thought a lot of a lot about since then
it's like what do your intentions really
matter when what you're making might or
might not offend somebody you know I've
got relatives that when I make a
Halloween or movie they get really
frustrated with me making something
that's very violent and they don't see
it as as entertainment or
or whatever value I might find in in
that as a genre they don't quite find
that same excitement you know and no
matter what my intentions are it's hard
to communicate that to someone that's
ready to be offended or ready to jump to
conclusion without those conversations I
mean as I guess like I'm kind of a like
look trying to look at all that in the
terms of saying like well what you're
butchering as long as you feel like
you're doing a good job it was like
getting whatever that attention was
across like I mean there's not but
there's nothing you can do if they won't
watch the movie so it's like okay but
but you know to like I don't know it is
it's a it's a new world in which that is
the case yeah for sure and then so then
the movie like did did get like
postponed like and got you know got read
was gonna get read basically like
universe so kind of like took it back
out and took it out as like a satire and
so like ad campaign which was a little
misleading probably because it was
dumber than a satire that's like and
there was like definitely like reviews
that were like like this movies know dr.
Strangelove kind of like yeah definitely
thought it was supposed to be dumber
than dr. chase yeah but uh but we got
you know we it was coming out it was it
was the weekend like it was the weekend
of shutting down the theaters that it
got released so it was but it's bit you
know that was the awesome like a weird
kind of foot nerd of just being like one
of the first three movies to be pulled
from the theaters and then just
immediately be put online which is like
you know since then I guess there's
trolls and some other oh and a
scooby-doo movie like that's kind of a
weird you know it's like a weird
footnote and the way
I feel like a lot more people saw the
movie and that was great for the movie I
also feel like a little bit kind of like
whoa but I like I don't want to be
contributing to like some sort of I mean
this was a unique scenario and in some
ways you know you and I both bounce
between movies and TV it is it's hard to
explain the difference you know as a
filmmaker making something that you know
was gonna be big and loud and and have
an audience and versus something that's
gonna play on TV do you I have mixed
emotions about both those what what are
your do you have pros and cons honestly
I have to admit that like now I just
think that you're kind of always making
it for the smaller screen because more
people are gonna see the type of movies
that you and I used to like the kind of
movies that like made them we watched in
film school that like made us the most
excited I don't know that I wouldn't
even go see in a movie theater anymore
you know like with five Easy Pieces like
playing in the movie theater right now I
go yeah movies you know that's but
that's the bigger questions like if it's
not gonna be these you know event movies
what is the sustainability you know and
we both have experience making from the
heart from the gut movies
independent-minded movies that when you
when you do get the opportunity to play
in a theater nobody goes so because they
don't have the big campaigns because
they don't have the big franchise
potential I mean it's not even a matter
of movie stars anymore I mean movie
stars help give movies finance
independent movies finance but I really
do think it's it's something different
that people go to movies for for the
most part in the masses that support the
the budgets that we look to to make a
modest independent minded film whereas
it's interesting when you know I made
I'd made before I did Pineapple Express
had made four independent
movies and you know you're always just
hoping you get into Sundance as as the
stepping stone or two you know you it's
never enough but then when you see a
crowd with a line and the reaction of
feeling that that enthusiasm of your
intention being received by hundreds of
people in a room together there's a
pretty exhilarating experience that it's
that I that I don't get when I might
think something so funny on on eastbound
and down or vice principals and I could
really feel great about landing the joke
but I'll never know I hope it works I
hope people laugh where they get it or
they or they find it but but not having
that active engagement at the same time
I don't have that stress on a on an
opening weekend where I know I'm gonna
be disappointed because whatever my
indie distributor didn't put much into
marketing and nobody knows the movies
even coming out I have to email all my
friends to tell their friends because I
don't have any I don't have any ability
up on the social media so I mean it's
like you know the thing is I guess like
it's yeah I'm okay I have to admit that
even even like and you know whatever
like even though I felt I have still
experience so many movies that I'd like
so much I did not experience as a viewer
I did not experience except for through
a home video watching scenario that like
even if it's if I'm like getting that as
I totally get because I know what you
mean when it comes to like you know in
something place you know like this movie
works this works like like I was in the
room and that's that bit works you know
like like that is the thing that's
irreplaceable and kind of the magic of
like why you want to do it um you know
I'm just trying to remember that like I
also some of the things that I love the
most
we're not like TV shows but like movies
that I I discovered on
video or something you know so I don't
know I absolutely didn't say like in
when we were in college we went to
college North Carolina School of the
Arts and we're in a little town in
winston-salem that doesn't have a movie
scene certainly doesn't have any sort of
Repertory Theater or any property so I
bet you I saw many of my 20 favorite
films for the first time in the library
wearing headphones you know I think in a
cubicle next to somebody else watching
something else right yeah right so it's
like it's like it's a it's a it's a
shame as the maker to like not have that
energy but I don't know that it ruins
the like art you know I feel like it's
like it's like and I still feel like you
know like I think about especially you
know I was thinking cuz what the corona
virus outbreak has done to me has like
made me be like very aware of like how
much I enjoy the different genre like
different genres and I was lucky enough
to like like you know mayor of each town
as is mostly a drama was like a mystery
to it but an incredibly naturalistic and
like very far away from the farce that
is the house like very far away and um
and that's been cool like I enjoyed
doing that and I think about you a bunch
with like you know when we did Prince
Avalanche from manglehorn by getting to
play like in different sand boxes and
it's like if those sand boxes have to be
I don't know I guess like if that if you
were making with it would it feel like
let's I think that it would still be as
important to me to like get to watch
Prince avalanche which I love like on
video as as in a theater I have a very
vivid memory of it playing at the IFC
theater opening weekend of that movie
and I'm sitting on a bench I'm supposed
to go to a QA that night opening
and there's I don't know 15 people in
the theater and I remember just being
sitting on a bench saying why am I like
this nothing that was a difficult movie
to make that's not an example of
something that's blood sweat and tears
that was actually a blast of three weeks
in the woods with your buddies but it
was interesting experiencing I'm so
proud of the movie and I feel like it
all came together in this like
unbelievable moment and then and then
you just can't find the enthusiasm from
from an audience that's when I started
thinking well I guess the world of
getting the right eyeballs is gonna be
in a different technical form other than
the fact that that movie played it at
the Berlin Film Festival was well
received and that was an amazing
experience an opportunity that I'll
never forget
so that was my that was my theatrical
release and everything else was
anticlimactic so you know maybe just
take it for what it is and it was a very
low-budget movie I also just think it we
should mention and in light of what Paul
was saying in and in respective Lynne
Shelton that that was she was in she had
a voice cameo in that movie and I just
remember being on the set of that movie
which was such a joyous experience and I
had a question about sag contracts on
low budget agreements and so I called
her to get some sort of reference point
for something and I was just listening
to her talk and I said by the way could
I use your would you mind acting in a
scene over the phone later and will
record your voice and then you'll play
the wife of Paul Rudd's character for a
montage that we'll use later and she
said okay so it was cool to have
connections with other filmmakers like
that where everybody can get together so
that to me that movie meant more than
you know more than the obvious box
office it was a spectacular emotional
experience in terms of its production
and and collaborator yeah absolutely I
mean I did yeah I did think about like I
guess like that's it that's I think
that's why that movies been on my mind
recently um that was like such a great
experience like it was like so because I
was on set
which was like really fun it's like been
a while since like we had been on set
together every day and watch you work it
was like I just want ya like it I'm I'm
I think that what I'm feeling kind of
coming out of this is like I want to
make sure that that is like the the goal
of making things should equally be like
this is what we're gonna do and I like
like you know it's like it's like some
people like have jobs where they go you
know an insurance office or whatever
it's like what we most of what we're
doing isn't like watching them finished
movies most of what we're doing is
making them and it's like trying to make
sure that you're like experience that is
fun I'm happy and that was like such an
educational one for me to watch and I
mean I come into you about it because it
was like for sure you just being like
let's go make this thing right now make
a t-shirt says that you know I'm 29 year
old sons and you know they're more
they're probably more into video games
and movies but we share movies with them
and we watch To Kill a Mockingbird
recently and things like that and but I
see they you know they're their world is
the devices that's like most kids these
days and and I think about and I can
roll my eyes if they're there with how
they're being exposed to some of these
masterpieces of you know I show them the
good the bad and the ugly the other day
and we're watching it on a small screen
television that you know that's a little
unfortunate but then at the same time I
remember my dad saying I dragged him to
the mall to go see a movie at a
multiplex and he'd be like this socks I
can't remember going to these movie
palaces with 3,000 seats and that's what
a movie is so I think it's always going
to going to evolve based on your
nostalgia of being a kid and finding
that fire you know so if it's it's for
me it was you know it was going to the
prestonwood mall movie theaters Dallas
Texas for my dad that was like right I
know I mean yeah like thinking about
um well I don't know I mean it becomes
the thing where it's like if you're a
movie maker like like just kind of like
knowing what your intention is and like
moving forward and hopefully like being
able to do it and whatever medium that
you those available to you know that you
can can do it in a we've been lucky to
get to do it having gone to school
together um in both in TV and in film
but um I I guess I'm reflecting a bunch
right now I'm like why to do it being
more about just like my favorite thing
is like being on set my favorite thing
genuinely is like being on set and I'd
be like take 3 and be like ok that
performance was awesome and the dolly
move was good and like finish the dog
moves was a little faster what happened
and then they racks there that would be
and we still have a performance similar
that's gonna like kill and like being
like let's do another take and like
talking to the whole crew and mainly
let's do this and just feeling the
energy yeah yeah we can do let's do it
again like let's all go make this thing
like that is really why I like to do
this
the adrenaline yeah yeah I Paul you're
back
I am indeed when we rambling you ready
for some questions yeah I try and group
these in by sort of topic and of course
as a few pandemic questions so we'll do
those first Steven asks how do you both
feel production is going to change once
filming comes back and then Gina asks do
you think as we go back into production
that indeed film production will be in
at an advantage because we always know
how to maximize efficiency of skeleton
crew make 10 background actors look like
50 etc
yes I do actually I you know the TV show
that I'm on was like I think it's um
unset every day was about like 93 people
or so and you know thinking about and
thinking about how to kind of like do
this we've been involved in a lot of
like beta luminary just kind of like all
of us sort of that were on the show
talking about it together because we
still have you know stuff to do and like
the solution is to make it more like an
indie movie I'd really like to do is
smaller so I don't know David have you
been having conversations I mean you
know we're talking about it because you
know we're trying to as soon as possible
we're gonna get into prep on the third
Halloween movie that script is pretty
intimate in its scope so it's not I'm
not worried about what we would have
been up against had we had to do the
second one but I you know I think
ultimately it's just gonna be about
being smart respectful healthy and I
don't know III I'm optimist so I'm
always looking at how do how we're gonna
take these scenarios and involve a
better environment I think we're gonna
be more efficient we're gonna be more
economical and that's from a huge
Hollywood temple to to a modest indie
movie we're just gonna figure out a way
to do it and do it safely you know one
of the one of the concerns I have is the
last two three years have been really
productive in just the variety of voices
that we're growing up with bringing
opportunity to and diversity to our
environment of crew and I think that's
been such a breath of fresh air and and
so valuable in terms of evolving our
stories and getting diversity of stories
but I worry that by having smaller crew
and more specific choices to make and
minimizing things I just want to make
sure that that's still a part of those
considerations that it's not just
filling in a blank but really making
soft will cure
raishin of crew that's gonna have those
special voices all around us I think are
gonna be in more intimate environments
are going to be even more valuable you
know one thing that we are talking about
and so kind of may answer that first
crystal like in concrete I know a lot of
people are talking about it's like that
it won't that it will simply be that
they're like groups of people that don't
of people that work on the like projects
that don't like physically see each
other that it's just all virtual you
know it's that though like vocations
people really don't interact with the
main crew except for a resume or
something
where that they like when the
construction people build the thing you
wait three days so that any bugs that
are there are dead and then the second
resting crew comes in and then they
dress it and then you wait three days
and then the chute comes and none of
those people it's just sort of like more
isolated in that scenario that those
kind of like ways which is gonna I feel
the same way like I feel like it's
actually gonna be like cool if we can I
do think there will be some growing
pains for certain people in terms of
like like you know like what there's
there's like a way especially sort of
within the like like traditional kind of
studio system like half of what all the
roles are that like there will need to
be some more it was it was pretty
segmented you know like there was an
Apple box from the props Department for
an activist and all that's different
from an Apple box from the grip
Department that the camera person sits
on and like different thing I think some
of that is gonna have to go away it's
just um that's okay a lot of
inefficiencies that go into expensive
budgets that make you know it's all it's
all it's all gonna evolve because if
movies can always be made more
economically I don't care how low-budget
your movie is there's always a way to to
strategize making it smarter you know
not just cheaper but smarter and
and I think the efficiency of a no I was
talking to who was I talking to
oh I was talking to Harmony Korine
yesterday too like we're kind of talking
having the same kind of conversation
about how we're gonna get things going
and he said we were talking it's like
it's like you're like you're imagine
you're a film crew on Everest like you
can't just call to the truck to get have
everything at your fingertips
yeah have thought about it have prepped
it and maybe don't be so greedy just go
there and live in the moment and live
with that crew and it's gonna be a
different different experience that I
think could be you know really
refreshing to a lot of people that I
know myself I get a little overwhelmed
when there are a huge crew and you don't
know everybody's name and who is this
guy that's always lurking around and and
the lack of intimacy I think can make a
very make for a very cold production
experience so I'm excited to see what
what streamlining it can actually offer
most importantly an actor and their
performance when they don't have a
million you know dude scratching your
armpit and all the boom light you know
and that's it not like I'm sure we
should get some more questions but just
out of curiosity have you worked with
like French hours before oh I love them
they're the best
I mean crews don't necessarily always uh
we did your highness in northern island
and and I just loved it they're like oh
yeah we shoot it straight through and we
go up dinner with our families so we
wrapped up 5:30 and go home like like
what a civilized way to work it was and
everybody's gonna it's a you work
through lunch and people bring food
around but you take a break and you know
whatever it I can't remember the
specifics that movie was a while ago but
it was a really wonderful way that keeps
both the momentum and energy of the day
going and to to force an ending that
kept that kept a civilized turnaround
for for a real life you know it was nice
yeah we shot that because of like being
outside like we shot the with they
weren't technically French ours like we
like it was it was in
French ours but it wasn't like it's like
we're only going to shoot this much
every day and that's what we're gonna do
and we're gonna call it and it does make
you know it only works if there's enough
of a plan that you don't go in sub life
long but don't you like not shooting -
no but it is it is great it's safer it's
so much safer I feel like for everybody
is like like more rested and driving
home yeah yeah
so that might stick hopefully that's
that the other pandemic question was
from Jack how do you guys think the
pandemic will affect the mainstream
appeal of horror films interesting the
the you know Craig and I both made
movies with Blum House last year which
is great I think we both had great
experiences working with them and those
are kind of the the Guru's of war right
now that I look to for for counsel in
the genre and and I ask the same
question and and they cited facts of
statistics of real world frustrations
amounting to cinematic experiences that
people want to go and scream you know
they want to go and let it out they want
it like that when you have hardship that
you're facing that it's a place that is
culturally acceptable to go and and and
and kind of exorcise your demons so to
speak so all statistics would point to a
trend of acceptance of that of a horror
movie in these times we'll see what the
reality is when when we get down to it
but I'm hopeful I think it's for me I
find more really Craig your movie was
exactly a horror movie but still had a
lot of the same kind of cathartic
I don't know energy to it or and yeah
and gore but I find it a great Jean
route to be able to you can you it's
kind of like that's your marquee
you can be very artful and I feel like I
can take a lot of creative risks
narrative Lee editorially in the genre
so I'm hopeful that it's something that
comes that continues to perform as as
strong as it has just because I'm having
a great time working with a great crew
great team of collaborators and and I
think the audiences will continue to be
there for us what was your motivation to
to move into horror and you know and go
to the granddaddy of them all of the
Halloween franchise well if you're gonna
if you're gonna do you got to go to the
granddaddy it was actually was a call
from Jason Blum who reached out and said
it was just an email one morning it said
Halloween question mark and and it I'd
always wanted I always want to do
something I've never done before I
always want to do you know I want to do
a documentary I want to do a musical I
want to do an animated feature there's a
lot just because I I'm never gonna be
the master of any craft but I can always
be a student and educate and in with
this as an opportunity to collaborate
with John Carpenter who's one of my
childhood idols and have him be the
godfather of a movie I'm working on
that's honoring his legacy that was that
was what what invited me outside of just
the curiosity of the genre I'm a fan and
and was excited to be able to do it I
wanna I want to be the behind the scenes
crew I'm trying to one of these days
we'll get it going along the horeb and a
mat for both of you if you can answer
this one or two pieces of horror film
screenwriting advice do an hour yeah
yeah so I would say you know you pretty
much need to have something either
either a scare or an poopy thing about
every five pages my advice would be keep
the script under 90 pages
and have a lot of no talking time like
they'll don't build up don't have people
blabbing too much people want to hear a
bunch of talking in a short and sweet
nobody wants to hang out for three hours
watching
well I'm apparently they I didn't make
it to the second it movie but that's
because I'm not gonna want to sit there
for that long I'm like I get an itchy
butt if it's not a Robert Altman movie a
a mumblecore horror film that probably
just not gonna work not my flavor
shorter movies guys come on what are we
doing here these two movies every time I
get the screeners it you know for
consideration at the end of the year I
start with a ninety 90 to 100 minutes
those gets let's get the first love I
may get to the ones over two hours
probably not Daniel says for both of you
but specifically to Craig relating to
compliance does having a controversial
filmography at all impact the process of
making a studio film and like and we've
created a hunt you know I think that I
hadn't ya know it didn't really affect
it and kind of at all I think that you
know it had been a while since the movie
you know closer to to when it happens
that would be the case but also I mean
like I started kind of working in TV
like right after compliance and the like
so it was actually okay for me I was not
their son dodge that year what was the
controversy around compliance it seemed
to me a lot of people didn't believe
that any of this would happen and
because they didn't know it was a true
event right once you find out it really
happened it changes the whole narrative
right yeah I mean I think that like that
movie has a lot like people
and if you have it it is it's
essentially about like you know power
and stuff and like if it's at all
something that if you're the kind of
person that's like oh I could see how I
could get tricked then you can kind of
absorb that movie in a certain way that
if you go to that movie with like any
defensive missile that kind of thing it
is more bothersome I mean that's sort of
in a nutshell
yeah people didn't think it was real and
thought that it was me just like
torturing people kind of through
watching it which are you answer that
question can you repeat the question
just having a commercial filmography
which oh but it's all over the place
which I've really screwed up any sort of
branding that might have been more
valuable if I wanted to you know make
the most amount of money you'd come up
with like the thing that you do that you
get hired to do you know nobody hired an
electrician to be a carpenter and and
you know once you establish yourself as
one thing it's probably in the your best
business interest to really you know
monitor that brand and make sure you
don't go off brand so that you can
become the biggest brand that there is
but I just keep doing
I keep getting sidetracked with
different things so I haven't been able
to successfully really establish that
which is part of the reason I think it's
fun to have a trilogy just so you can
say I have a trilogy that's pretty
exciting and then you've established
something you can actually capitalize on
it rather than running away from any
success because I've done that before a
lot of the big directors that have name
recognition don't stay in the same
sandbox do they they had they don't make
the same film twice and they attack all
these different genres I always look at
people like Alan Parker who I think is a
very underrated certainly been acclaimed
in his day but but the diversity of his
filmography is pretty incredible so I
look at him as somebody very
inspiring in that way because it's
everywhere from road to wellville.shoot
the moon.white to Midnight Madness I
would love it I I mean back to the
theatrical adrenaline man that the
midnight premiere of Halloween at TIFF
you know festival that I've been to I
think was like eight of my movies but
that one in particular and I'm a guy
that goes to bed at 10:30 so to ask me
to stay up past midnight is like trouble
but it was an amazing event amazing
experience and and for the movie that I
know I've got in the can that's ready to
be very close to being ready to see I'm
even more excited about this one than it
was the last one so whatever it's
whatever its format whatever its release
you know I'm ready to get the
butterflies out of my stomach and get it
seen so few Craig from Steven what's the
narrative and hunt started to change how
much input into a new direction with the
marketing campaign did you have oh I
mean that sort of was kind of it was
like a there were certainly group
discussions but it was also it was also
like kind of led by by the I think
really smart you know like market
environment of Universal trying to make
sure that they kind of were trying to
show a different version of the story
which you know was certainly what
because in some ways like the the
marketing campaign had had maybe been
something that people had felt was maybe
causing some of the controversy more so
than the film itself so you know we
tried our best to like make that make
sense
Don Aldo says to both of you can you
talk about sons some of the challenges
or offer advice and the transitioning
from an indie project to a bigger
mainstream film or obviously big
television yeah I don't know challenges
I haven't had that's why I very often
say instead of independent films I would
say independent minded because I think
it's more of a mindset than it is a
reality because most of the studio
experience I've had not only do you have
creative independence you also have the
money to do what you wanted to do so I
find that kind of liberating so hey I'd
like some more days here's why there's a
system to say okay oh and I find that I
found very independent-minded
collaborators at a studio level on all
of my studio experiences so I find
there's more resources as long as you
have a vision for what you're doing and
everybody understands you've been very
clear communicating with the movie
you're one of me pointing to make is and
that doesn't change and you can I'd say
the only challenge would be how flexible
you are when it comes to pleasing an
audience when you start test screening
the movie and seeing what people
responsive or responding to if if you're
willing to fight for things that
audiences hate or if you're willing to
embrace the things that they're loving
and and they go maybe slightly against
your instincts that's that's the only
time where it becomes a little morally
challenging like I've been in the only
difficult time I've had in city
experiences is trying to decide well
should I keep that joke in that I'm the
only one laughing
even though 600 people in a theatre yeah
and sometimes I do but those are those
are conversations you have or I guess
I've had a couple of conversations and a
difficult one once where a studio said
you know you've test screening the movie
I don't know we probably I like to test
screen a movie a lot so I think four or
five times and this one scored the best
will give you X number of dollars to
market it this one is your favorite will
give you the other number to market it
and you have to choose its
times you're like well what's more
important the three minutes that I love
with a movie or a bigger marketing push
to help make that movie get received
because sometimes that's it's helpful
and and if you're gonna make a studio
movie that is built to be an audience
experience you got to think about the
audience and what they're looking to
experience and how to access that
audience when they need to be challenged
because sometimes they they don't need
to be handed it they need to be you know
they need to understand in a different
way you know so I just think marketing
is a bigger part of the conversation in
every way than actual studio filmmaking
studio production right I mean
everything that David said for sure I I
guess like for me like you know it is
like a bit of a thing where it's like
well why are you moving into making a
studio movie like what for me getting
more people to see it as like a valuable
thing right like or a thing that I
wanted to explore have have have that
experience so it's not hard to make the
decisions well it's it's as long as
you're clear as to like what you're what
you're choosing why you're choosing to
do it you know it's like well it's like
I do a lot of people like react to this
or that thing you can I think that it
makes it pretty easy to navigate those
conversations or there's a good Keystone
to like go back to in your brain like in
a really practical level to answer the
question like what's like what are the
challenges of like I was like working
and moving into that kind of level is
like I do think that there is probably
some I definitely remember some level of
slight anxiety that had to do was kind
of feeling like I had been making movie
like I've been cheating like I've been
making movies like without like knowing
the right way to do this
that thing and then just having to kind
of get over that and just realize that
it's like everybody else came here in
the same way and like you you know my
question would be about that anxiety of
getting from something small that you
felt you could control then you have
control over to something so much bigger
that's like yeah it's a big deal it's
about control I think I look at it less
about control and more about leadership
like if you can have a conversation
where you're confident and and you're a
likeable personality giving that
confidence people are going to want to
be a part of that and they're gonna want
to if you're a jerk I don't care what
you're making nobody wants to talk to
you and if you're insecure and have
anxiety about everything people want
time to spend money on that personality
that it is a you know sometimes it
happens but it's frustrating I know for
the for financier for studio executives
or or whoever you're responding to
unless you're writing the check yourself
so I just think if you're if you're a
good if you have good leadership skills
and you can be persuasive and you have a
valid opinion as to why then it doesn't
it doesn't it rarely turns into a fight
unless you're just dealing with some
somebody that's trying to follow some
sort of redundant formula of another
movie and you're wanting to carve your
own path actually we need persuasive
that was what I was about say to like
it's just about like finding like how to
be persuasive right like like you know
that's part of the Davos like directing
is like so be like hey this is the
version of the story that I think we'd
be surprising and new and cool and like
when you can confidently do that even if
you don't know what the special effects
doing or you know like any sort of the
effects thing that you might not know
like you can kind of get through all of
it because everybody you meet where your
job is actually to like get people that
do know how to do that stuff to like
help you do it you know confidence also
means not being scared to ask a question
when you don't I mean of course
so if you hire smart people that are
cool and and help you look good and you
help you achieve the shot you know half
the time I'm still on set and it looks
to the VP and I say I want to go put a
camera over here is that it you know
what's the best device to do do we need
to get a crane out can we go to the top
of the dollar do we need to get a wire
out that we you know put it on a twelve
step ladder I mean you know so I think
hiring hiring people that can help you
communicate your vision and you've had
as many conversations beforehand to be
able to give everybody the skills nobody
wants to be making last-minute decisions
and scrambling to fix things so as men
as much preparation and as many non
condescending you know helping hands
that you can have through those
conversations just it's just yeah I
don't I don't see any awkward transition
from from make from it you're selling
your story and you have more toys and
tools to do it
you do all that stuff in a little budget
level too usually right yeah John asks
hi John what are the things you've
learned about working with actors
particularly stars and how the old
methods of working evolved I mean I
would say that that there's really not
much difference between the star and
another and I guess I you know I assume
you mean like celebrity kind of level
people like than any other actor I think
of the job as like one in a lot of ways
of being like it's a combination of your
collector in a play you would get to
like rehearse rehearse rehearse rehearse
rehearse and then be like this is
definitively the version of how to do
this after six weeks of like like going
through performance you don't have time
and it's not really built that way to do
that on a movie or television show so in
some ways your job is like one of which
just say like here's what my
instincts that like writing kind of is
like saying that we should be trying to
do here is some other things that that
like my script analysis so to speak has
like has like told me like are kind of
important things that we should be
trying to make sure happen in this and
we can do them in different takes and we
can like we can have options and like
trying to collect options I mean that I
look at it like more like you're like a
first base coach just kind of like being
like okay that performance is really
interesting you can steal second if you
can if if like you see opportunity to do
this or that you know be or thing in it
like it's a support it's just you have
to support the people and like for me
like it doesn't it's the same if they're
famous or not famous like everybody
wants that's what everybody is like
hoping that there's somebody else
watching them they don't have to they
can be more in the moment yeah I would
say the only difference is there's a lot
of experience that they might have so I
always like to start the conversation of
like how do you like to work do if I'm
doing a scene with you and three actors
would you like me to start on your
coverage or would you like me to start
on the wide shot would you like me to
let you get warmed up and then I'll end
on you
you know if there's if you've got three
day players in a movie star
I let the movie start call the shots in
terms of creating warmed or hey I've
been up all night I got it memorized let
me go while I'm fresh and I'll do you
all start on the close-up and and and
film her first and then and then move
around when I do give a little priority
to process to a movie star particularly
if it's a unless I'm trying to
antagonize them for some sicko away
reason but but I do every actor has a
different method and some like to stick
to script and if you throw them a curve
ball and say let's throw the script away
on this one they just stand there
quietly and don't know because it they
don't have their cue and so you have to
deal with that actor differently than
someone that's able to improvise and
can't memorize the script anyway you
know and some of the greatest actors can
work in in any number of processes and
and I think just starting I just started
with with questions and trying to build
an environment that's very positive I
rarely go in and say don't do this or no
that's not what I'm looking for but I go
in there with kind of affirmation and an
agreeable lovable way to finesse what
they're giving me to be what I'm looking
for we are out of time there's a comment
here from Lauren for you David by the
way I love prints Avalanche sort
understated wits Q name with you and
emile hirsch
amazing I thought she was there Halle
geez to everyone who asked questions we
didn't get to last question for both of
years for all these coffee talks is just
what are you watching and I said David
you said you're not watching or reading
much I'm watching very little but I did
watch the greatest movie I've ever seen
and I hadn't seen it in 30 years but the
Black Stallion is on Amazon and and I've
always liked the black style you know no
but I watched it last week and it blew
my mind I mean I haven't seen it since I
was 12 and on every technical level that
movie is I wrote the BP after as soon as
I was done watching it cuz I was like I
haven't I'm a cried in a movie it's not
even a sad movie but I'm just like
weeping it how miraculous it is that
that movie exists and so if you think
you know the blacks on you but you
haven't seen it in a while that's so
well it's amazing knowledge sure you're
gonna watch more Caraballo movies
yes I mean the best the best all the
stuff with the boy and the horse is just
it's real magic its movie and that's the
thing that you're never gonna get in
your video game engines when you're
trying to recreate things that we can't
because of the evolved technology and
we're trying to you're never gonna be
able to do what they did and what was
early eighties with a kid bareback
riding a horse galloping through seek
ocean I mean just the times gone it's
not gonna exist and so but hanging on to
what
what can be these both epic and intimate
moments of cinema it's a yeah it can't
be done artificially let's say yeah
should be on everyone's watchlist I
agree
anything else you mentioned the dustbowl
documentary from Ken Burns right and
then the other thing I did watch that a
series Dave I just finished last night
that's pretty funny if you need a if you
need a beer and a laugh at the end of
the night I recommend Dave okay and I
want you to check out your Halloween
maybe absolutely yeah you know let's
hope theaters have a recovery and
whatever that experience involves two
let's I'm gonna be there to try to
support it and hopefully yeah hopefully
we'll be seeing movies together and non
screens again the first one is playing
on prime right now right yeah raiga nice
any recommendations view I recently
watched I've been watching this Swedish
filmmaker Roy Anderson oh great yeah
they're doing shot on the branch yeah
the pigeon under sat on a branch
reflecting on existence is the songs
from the second floor is actually like
really yeah but they're all kind of like
like they're these like likes there's
something about them kind of I don't
know that there are these little
portraits of a moment there's not a lot
of like big kind of huge emphasis on
plot at all that has been fun to watch
right now for me um I've been watching
that and then as far as TV I just
actually started watching and I'm really
having fun watching on becoming a God in
Central Florida the Showtime show is
cool like it's worth
check that out yeah and if people wanna
check out the hunt you said it's on
iTunes it's on the map on all the major
like VOD platform jokes yeah and we'll
look out for mayor from Eastern later in
the year when you get you have to finish
it first right yeah hopefully hopefully
we'll be bringing that to you well this
has been a coffee talk with film
independent reminder that you can still
join a membership is open to all and if
you join in may you get a discount on
your membership just check out us from
independent
org and film independent on Twitter and
Instagram but just leave me to say thank
you to our guest today David Gordon
Green thank you David you're talking you
guys Rick great to see you keep keep up
keep working stay healthy stay
productive and Craig Zobel Thank You
Craig thanks so much thanks for having
me thank you both we'll hopefully we'll
do this again soon when you when you
make more movies and more shows let's
shove you back so thank you thank you
and stay healthy
see ya thanks so much
you